what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we're gonna watch House of
the Dragon episode 5 today John how's it
going I'm great and excited in all the
things how are you I'm doing well thank
you for asking it's really kind and
courteous and and Regal of you to do
ladies and gentlemen leave a like for
House Targaryen also subscribe click the
notification Bell to get notified when
the time Jump begins and full length
Reaction watch along as we sync up with
your own copy of House of the Dragon
available for our super sexual rejects
over at our patreon page it's a good
page to be a part of last but not least
thank you to the team over at prepper
for helping us edit down these
highlights I think my glasses are ready
to go let's go
rabbit dear you care for some company
I'd rather ride alone
according to you don't need no man
why does this feel so tense don't get
lit up with arrows any minute
he picked a really good Obi-Wan disguise
that's the wife
what brings you to the
way more of it I'll have you at last
quite our marriage oh it's his actual
wife
what will you do now
will you strike the child down
oh
[Music]
sing
whoa she had The High Ground
oh she paralyzed yeah
you cold-hearted bastard I knew you
couldn't finish
[Music]
if you had not been so relentless in
advance
you want to be hand to the king
these are all very valid points
[Music]
Jesus
this poor family The Grandmaster
delivered a tea to the princesses
tea yes
that the grand maester himself brought
at the direct
I thought for Melos himself
my condition must be something very
serious
What happiness it is
to have been wrong
hahaha
I would love it if he was actually just
sincere that whole time I know didn't
had no cunning plan up his sleeve
princess
are you well
Damon's wife the lady Ria Royce has
passed
a hunting mishap
she was thrown from her horse
her neck and skull both crushed in the
fall and then a rock fell from the sky
onto her face
God's will it
wish to propose a marriage between your
son Selena
and my daughter an heir princess Rainier
we would like to know how the succession
will be handled
can I presume that
their children would take their father's
name you are not proposing the Targaryen
Dynasty end with my daughter simply
because she is a woman
what I want
renero's children she'll take their
father's name
however
it will be a hyphenate first born
ascends the iron throne
he or she will do so bearing the name
Targaryen this is an equitable
compromise
[Music]
it's gonna be the terrible father-in-law
I prefer roast duck to Goose
I cannot say why
there are those who like us very well
I find it a bit greasy for my taste you
haven't had my cousin's Goose we perform
our duty to our fathers and to the realm
be fit
open marriage
that's right man let's do it very modern
so Progressive for her time I'm sure
Lena was already taken with her
she's grown quite calmly these last few
years you know his true nature nah he's
gonna fix him
he will outgrow it
oh he's gay yeah the Rainer will be
Queen of the Seven Kingdoms and you will
be her King consort
you wear your crown today
you'll need a sworn protector
but he still needs to Bear children yeah
they're gonna do their duty to their
fathers and then you know
off with you
I've heard you say that you are to be
married off at your at your father's
whim with no thought given to the
yearning of your own heart and now the
day comes
chosen for you
oh this guy's hurt man if there were
another path one that led to Freedom
would you tread it
asking you
yeah you gotta do it man
she won't but no there's no way
a marriage for love
not for the crowd
I want that Crown though it is my duty
to marry a noble man from a great house
and Selena will make a fine husband
and you can be my squeeze I've gone to
leave to pursue his own interests Anna
Tony's Grant to be the same talk about
the duck and the goose
my white cloak it is the only thing I
have to my [ __ ] name oh
the Iron Throne looms larger than me
larger than anyone in my family
so Kristin
[Music]
wow
choice and consequences
that poor guy yeah you could hear his
heart cracking during that pause all
identity is just shattered my father
received an accounting of
a lapse of morals
does he know about this rumor I don't
think he do
not unaware that in flush of Youth
there may be errors made
reaches in resolve
breaches or rather lapses happened to
your grace no no no you need to have a
bit more clear in your sentences my
queen I was like wait my dude just wait
my oath has been broken
no I have Dishonored myself
I deserve no consideration
than David yeah
I would ask only this
rather than gelding me
and having me tortured you would
sentence me massively to death wow you
were the best guy this is why text
messaging friends exist
he's so much easier no idea what I just
found out
the legion have always brought his grace
relief
oh my God that arm
I know it's disgusting
Oh I wanna I wanna appeal it
I have to have good
some might call that good fortune
it hardly makes a good song
is it no better to live in peace than to
have songs sung after you are dead
it depends
another Lord might assure me that I
would rise like egg on the Conqueror
given the chance
Grace that is your right
it is perhaps best not to know
I feel so bad for her
the most steady decline of any character
I feel like shit's about to go down yeah
this is gonna be another red wedding I
don't think it's gonna be that down
a pinkish wedding congratulations Your
Grace you have made a fine match for the
princess thank you Lord Jason
what's Damon up to
[Music]
uh she's put together
Goose right there
oh here he is
even there to mourn the wife
[Music]
oh my gosh smug bastard
we joined together in Celebration
tonight is only its beginning
the honor the crowd
with House Targaryen and
oh no what's about to go down
I feel like viserys is gonna die tonight
do you know what color it glows when Old
Town calls its banners to warm
green
huh
congratulations
[Music]
what a blessing this is for you
stepdaughter
[Music]
please be seated
it sure is so uncomfortable it's for the
crest
it's my come Jesus moment writer
wedding
between my daughter your future Queen
and Selena valarian
air to drift
she's going to confront her right yeah
she's got to
or spill something out I feel like
something is gonna go down
[Music]
this is the awkward glances episode yeah
I know
foreign
[Music]
oh my God everyone's just piecing
everything together by the looks
he's gonna be the one to do something
yeah there's gonna be somebody
answer for their crimes
even targaryens
who are you sir Gerald Royce all the
room's done
I don't even know who you are I am
cousin to your late lady wife ah yes
terrible thing
positively bereft
you know better than anyone it was no
accident were you confessing some guilt
so Gerald
accusation
you know inking's Landing men are made
to answer for their Slanders even old
prawns like you
don't talk to Peter Jackson like that
lady rear and I had no heirs as her
husband whatever she was she now passes
to me
territory of runestone
after my niece's wedding I plan to fly
to the area and petition Lady Jane
myself perhaps I'll see you there sir
oh my God
fly to the area it's okay buddy you gave
it your all
[Music]
is like the unspoken truths episode yeah
everyone just like knows what's really
going on he's not saying something
[Music]
oh oh no oh oh God has anybody ever told
you your lady is pretty as your brother
why are you flatter me my friends
oh sorry Terry about your lady wife
Debbie I wasn't no I have some time oh
you're so Christian called
won't protect them look at him
the man is fully strong
I believe sir Kristen has bloodied that
white cloak of his with your bridesmaid
perhaps that is something with my remedy
[Music]
oh my goodness she knows your secret
but now you know who's
guys leave Kristen alone this is a
terrible wedding he's been through
enough
this is worse than the right way it's
more Awkward than the Red Wedding
in some ways more painful
watch we are both deeply invested in
this Union
Selena was quite dead to me
as I know
the princess is to you
swear to each other to God then
and their secrets
because if those are kept safe
is so real
that's a great shot with the two
overlapping faces
something's building and I don't know
what yeah I'm getting like a panic
attack vibe
there's too much attention to all this
chaos
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
stop get you're in public like this foot
away at least
[Music]
[Music]
no no
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is happening
something else is going on
[Music]
some Bag I'll have lanor
oh no yeah he got involved
[Music]
oh no
yep
[Music]
oh
my god wow
foreign
[Music]
to join Two Souls as one
here here we fired he's gonna kill
himself for the trees
[Music]
on your mind
foreign
oh my goodness I am yours in your mind
[Music]
the nor of house Valerian reneur of
House Targaryen
to be man and wife
now
and forever
sir Kristen
[Music]
wow I wasn't expecting that yeah oh my
God
ah
what a cursive day
imparted ending yeah
whoa
that's some rough stuff that's hardcore
what I would have paid to be a fly on
that wall
way up high on that wall I don't know
who's winning
there's this some juicy in every corner
when are they gonna play you make me
wanna shout
so it was missing really
that's the only thing
oh yeah
oh
yeah
that was good
that was fun was the King dead I think
the king might be dead especially if
we're about to time job be very
surprised if they wheel them in like I'm
still kicking
but you never know I mean maybe that'll
be his thing maybe he'll be cursed with
long life and terrible terrible health
back here
yeah
there had to have been a lot of people
who saw
Damon put his hands on her face I feel
like there would have had to have been
people paying attention or someone
nearby who's aware of the allegation in
this place that's really well done build
up because you're like
shit's about to go down and I'm not even
sure what it is but something terrible
is about to happen from which character
is going to spark it up and I love that
too when [ __ ] really does go down like
it's it's vague as to exactly what
happens
it just yeah it just devolves into this
chaos it was awkward [ __ ] I loved it yep
tremendously cringe-worthy filmmaking in
a good in a in a good painful way I was
so impressed that episode because
from just a technical standpoint for
writing because it at first there was a
part of me that was like okay
there's been a lot of like public
knowledge that that after this episode
there's going to be the time Jump that
eventually happens where
um you know like some of our characters
are going to be replaced by other actors
and such and
I was like okay some of this seems like
this is a setup episode for what's to
come like they're setting some stuff up
and I I was kind of worried that it was
all that's all it was mainly going to be
with like a few like little bits but it
managed to be just a very in-depth
provocative episode again as you'd want
that was that felt so immediate and also
did a wonderful job successfully setting
up the future like it did both like
simultaneously so well because there's
such a great groundwork laid for the
future that is off to just a terrible
start like it's just the worst start it
wrecks the chess board and then sets it
back up for you yeah yeah and I think
that's really that's really impressive
uh that they did that because a lot of
times you know you often walk away with
shows going you know it's like a setup
episode it's a good setup episode and
it's rare you can walk away going it did
both incredibly well like I'm actually
looking forward to seeing what the what
the future is uh and and what that time
Jump will be which I'm sad to see like
the the Millie Alcott alcaccia Alcock
yeah who plays renera I'm I'm so
disheartened to see her go because again
delivering another Exquisite performance
just just a powerful one and such a such
a turning point episode for this
character you know like that scene that
she has with Sir with uh Kristen on the
boat when he is proposing like why don't
we just Escape let's just like live our
romantic lives out and just be in love
and forget this hierarchy this thing
you've always sort of dismissed and had
had issues with that you've always
confided in me and you're seeing how
she's like obviously tempted to a
certain degree but she has to hide that
because this episode was so much about
dealing with what's going on underneath
the surface something the show has all
done since the beginning this whole
episode especially the wedding that's
what it just was was like okay there's
[ __ ] building there's ship percolating
which is going to be the one that tips
over yeah which is the first thing
that's gonna really collapse it's gonna
light the Powder Keg and the main thing
that got it going was uh the thing that
made it on board for us to me it seems
like Renee knew that he was probably gay
beforehand right which made her go like
yeah I'll marry him because I could do
whatever I want yeah yeah she's got too
much knack for strategy not to see the
opportunity in that but the the ace and
the like the thing that she had to work
with was the fact that she he had a
lover
and so she and now both of those have
been just I mean I don't know what's
going to become a Christian and after
that moment with Alice with Allison
I don't know what Allison's plan is it
seems like Allison's now like she's in a
Solo position I'm almost
cersei-esque almost just someone who's
you're like oh yeah she's Queen but now
there's no king with her yeah and now
she has to worry about her children what
could be stripped from her in the future
yeah what could happen to her well-being
and maybe she needs to Harbor this
information and somehow use like you're
like okay what's everyone plotting now
everyone's an enemy
everyone's using each other even more
aggressively than they were before all
these bonds are even more tenuous now
and more yeah just like stress worn yeah
I love it it's great and then you got
Damon who's just waiting to cause all
kinds of chaos just walks in yeah every
time he enters the room it's it's solely
to just cause the the most effective
chaos it's just funny how they like they
kill off the wife at the very beginning
and that's their first time meeting her
right yeah and now we've heard about her
a bunch of times just solely from his
perspective where everyone's like she's
fine and he's like I hate that [ __ ] and
she shows up but she's like compelling
for those moments she's on yeah just
died
because she was I thought oh it was
gonna be interesting to like unpack here
but again this show does a really good
job like I think that unspoken the
unspoken truce theme they had you know
circulating throughout that whole
wedding is a big part of what the what
the writing kind of carries over
throughout this whole show
because
it weirdly like of course I would like
to have seen more with like it would
just hit that much harsh much more harsh
if we had gotten to know her a little
bit yeah prior to that moment but in
that instance you get so much of the
idea of like her grasp on and her whole
point of view about Damon the marriage
and it kind of seems like she wanted a
husband too you know in that little
moment she's sort of wanted an actual
husband yeah and and feels like like
loads this man hates him and also feels
hurt to him betrayed by him yeah it's
like she actually might have wanted that
and I had to get stuck with you the
worst version of it who doesn't yeah who
with whom I cannot enjoy any of The
Spoils of this position it's just oh
it's so cold and
it's like what is Damon going to be
doing now and like what's the this this
war within the the crumbling targaryens
is all with it and it's so fun to watch
it's fun it is it's it's fun it's very
messy yeah in a very sort of uh Gallows
kind of way and yeah like I that seemed
like even though that's not like a main
plot character that felt like one of
those surprising sort of Stark deaths
where yeah you just meet this person you
kind of get that I loved that we spend
that little perspective build you you
remarked like why do I feel so
uncomfortable just watching her ride
through this Valley and then she comes
upon Damon in the most like ominous but
also like oh okay it's just him kind of
way but uh yeah I don't know just like
the it's such a cold scene and it says
so much about him in a way like it's a
bummer because yeah it's not really
about her as much as it is just like
showing just the the the depth of his is
I don't know yeah just coldness keeps
coming back to mind because you can see
a way in which this Alliance could be
beneficial in some way shape or form but
Damon doesn't seem interested in any of
that and when he comes back around with
um sir I can't remember his name Jaren
or whatever the other you know the
relative of hers like it's so painful to
watch that guy step up and to really
feel like he's got an opportunity to
stick it to Damon only for Damon to turn
around and be like oh hey by the way I
just inherited your entire place of
living your entire Homeland you know can
you arrange that for me yeah like it's
yeah it's just so it's Damon remains
this fascinating character because the
more
it's a testament to Matt Smith's
performance in those moments because
every time he's just sitting there
observing you're like what is this guy
thinking and there are little moments
where you're like yeah I can I can still
see like a glimmer of a human in there
but so much of him is just
uh like a
like a chaotic evil character like a
chaotic neutral character or something
like that where it's like I I could
never really I said this before and it
rings true throughout and and through
this episode like it seems like he
almost never comes in with a plan
except to watch things twist well I
think he he always has
there's always a desire though behind
his actions there's always somewhat of a
I think the the show introduces him like
he's a wild card you don't know what
this guy's gonna do he's just manic he's
the new he's Joffrey but more
intelligent you know but yeah with more
tact but then uh you know you quickly
learn that no he's actually a lot more
clever and conniving because it's like
that you don't exactly know why he all
they've really showed us is that he
doesn't like her and then he kills her
in the beginning of this episode there's
got to be a reason why but he died I
don't unless you like unless it's in the
book unless you really understand the
politics already beforehand where you're
like oh [ __ ] he killed her so that means
he's gonna inherit because they don't
have a hair like if you're my Heritage
happen to know the world that well but
you really don't know why he did that
and then when you find out they're like
oh it's actually a really big political
gain he can have now but it's like why
why that political game because you can
buy both versions you could buy that
he'd just be so cold is to be like no I
just hate her and I finally had an
opportunity to get her out of my way but
then yeah you see the bigger picture
plan and it is like wow that is
smart and also your your choice to now
resurface that this event gives you the
power that much more in that situation
as if it as it wouldn't have done if you
would like shown up to her funeral and I
actually do tend to read the top
comments on on these reactions that we
do and I remembered that there were
people because we were talking about the
the when when they did fornicate Kristen
and renera and that people because we
were like you know it's interesting to
see like a whole scene of like
debauchery and giving it to these sexual
pleasures and then you get a more of a
tender loving scene which I I think it
was executed that way but there were a
couple of people who were like I
actually didn't find a tender at all I
thought it was like it was just a
manipulation of power that were narrowed
it and and uh you know also it broke his
oath his vow and I kind of forgot about
that angle I I forgot about that in
admittedly I forgot about oh yeah that's
right they have part of chivalry is yeah
I forgot all about that and then to
watch the effects come into this episode
and how much that has
just like
he sleeps with her and it's been a
little bit of time he's like obviously
madly in love with her he's sacrificed
his whole commitment
because of giving in to this
um desire for her
and now he can't even have her and he's
got to watch her get married off and
like you're just watching this guys who
is so Noble and honorable yeah it just
succumbed by the end just pulled down to
the bottom here or just annihilates this
person at a wedding who
why exactly was it him
do you think that he murdered
yeah like I'm like threatening or did
someone had a secret on that I I didn't
I didn't quite know it's like it does
it's I'm not here going why it just
makes no sense at the same time like I
don't fully know why he he chose him as
a Target in the in the moment just the
first time watching it because I would
like to go back and revisit the scene
the the way it sort of read to me amid
all that chaos was sort of that was the
last straw given that was the last
interaction we saw him have and that
puts him in this precarious new position
of like oh yeah you know now I'm part of
this like apparatus of secrets and lies
and things and when everything breaks
out I felt like it was a almost like a
proximity thing where like they're both
together or in close range of each other
and then maybe in all the chaos or
something like that it got to the point
where
it seemed like one of them was attacking
the other one like I'm not sure because
yeah when when uh maybe he wanted to
dissolve this whole thing
maybe I mean yeah maybe he just doesn't
like I I don't have to lie yeah I think
either way what happened I don't know
exactly what got them in you know
whether Kristen was like I gotta find
you and kill you it seemed more like a
random just boiling over of yeah of his
guilt and of his just not wanting to be
a part of this rig the regret the guilt
the pain of the conversation before with
renero where he yeah he lays out this
very pure Noble like let's run away
together and just have a life and all
that stuff mounts and then you know it's
like Allison learns about this and yeah
it's like his his whole Spirit seems
like it's been demoralized and then yeah
that exchange with lenor's bow there uh
it just seems like it yeah it it just
solidifies his descent into this immoral
place that I'm sure is eating in his
soul and yeah that's probably then just
the target of like I am overcome and I'm
just letting it out on you because
that's exactly not what I want well at
the same time by letting it out on him
though they both
now just they're married
just married now and they don't have the
things they can have their fun with yeah
and it's like even if it was like well
you're you're still free to go out and
you know meet people and whatever it's
like yeah that that doesn't even
probably appeal anymore because they've
both suffered such a yeah like a heart
loss well yeah I wasn't because you you
there's the show reading like clearly um
re-explains it that it's not just about
going out and you know getting all kinky
and stuff and having multiple lovers
it's about being with the one you really
love yeah uh and now they don't get to
be with the one they really love
I thought that was a good use of that
metaphor because at first you're like
thinks they're trying to say he's gay
but I also think it's just like yeah I
know you love somebody for real and so
do I so yeah I thought that was a good a
well-articulated theme yes yeah very
well done stuff and uh so painful
and then they just skip all the
celebrations and all the festivities and
they just go right to the wedding and
you just feel the that much more Hollow
for everyone involved they're just like
they're barely looking at each other and
they're like talking all soft and yeah
you can just tell like what a horrible
night and then viserys heals over but I
I love the show for what it explores
with this political game and and the the
the how these how when your emotions
just they they simmer they simmer when
you're rip you push it down for
something that is like Duty yet you see
with the consequences of that can be and
and you're you watch something like
runera give in to sleeping with Kristen
and then how that's destroyed something
you're watching like
renera who's been like such an amazing
character and he'd never Associated at
all it's like a bad person and then at
the at the climax of this wedding yeah
you watch like just the depravity of all
these things that happen because of
things that she participated in or part
about part took and you know she's like
that whole divide with Allison at the
end which is like Allison's just finding
out the truth everything with Kristen
Damon even like Damon's just all over
the place here he's like freaking trying
to sleep with the one girl or like
tempting her and then he's like I won't
remember just want this God damn it yeah
anyway so yeah that that situation at
hand and then of course now he she chose
him
um what's the name again
uh the the Valerian yeah uh Lenor Leonor
she chose she chose Lane ore yeah
specifically she was given a choice
chose him and through that choice now
led to Leonor losing the one he loves
it's just like this major collapse
all the surrounding things that not not
solely her obviously there's a whole
bunch of other players involved here
but it is cool to see how it's from
She's the central point of it all you
know uh it's it's just it's just gnarly
[ __ ] oh yeah and it's like the such a
web of consequences comes out of of what
in that episode feels like such an
intimate isolated you know heat of a
moment and uh and two I love the way
this episode reveled in especially once
you get to the ceremony
in this quality and it's throughout both
Game of Thrones and this this sort of
propping up of customs and of
appearances despite the fact that
everyone in the room practically is side
eyeing each other and knows at least a
version of what's really going on here
and knows that this is kind of a sham
and yet we're all kind of here to make
face and to you know enjoy celebrating
and being watched but like when the
chaos breaks out you can feel that
tension that lives underneath and it
makes for a good sort of just audio
visual metaphor for the struggle between
order and statecraft and just the base
human instincts yeah and that something
like this that is based on base human
instincts that is about attraction and
and you know arousal has led to all of
not every part of this but so much of
the conflict that boils over here
there's also this other quality that
this episode really like what I think
Game of Thrones is generally explored
and this show
especially
of
you know like something as simple as
listening to your heart's desires and
just being appreciative of what you have
versus this Chase for legacy yeah and
then you watch as the king who did you
know pretty much take the more pacifist
route has made some questionable choices
that could have dire consequences for
the future of Targaryen for the House
Targaryen
which will obviously
um it's already begun it's it's already
begun
and yet on his last day she's like
lamenting and like just so sorrowful
he's just weak doesn't have he's not
even with his Queen
for like most of his the most of the
time yeah he's not even with her her
absence is large exactly yeah it looms
very large and green dress and he's
there wondering like what well people
even remember me like I'm nothing you
know yeah and did I do the right thing
by trying to keep peace and then it's
interesting how all he wanted to do was
try to keep peace and by the by trying
to keep peace he is now set up for the
future generation to pretty much help it
crumble yeah yeah you know which is
which yeah it always reminds me of the
time machines that whole thing about
like the more you try to to avoid an
outcome you'll you'll just kind of Bring
It about uh and yeah like I thought that
was such a wonderfully like again hats
off to Patty considine because like it's
such an intimate moment and I thought
part of me was like maybe he's just
gonna die right now yeah um but yeah
like and and that is interesting to see
contrasted between the two of them
because they're both in some ways kind
of pondering that and the sort of like
what this duty of of you know being the
king or the queen does to you and it's
like he's sitting here going you know I
had a pretty good life but yeah did I
did I not you know risk enough you know
for greatness and then you have renera
who's in this position of like yeah
given an offer to throw all that away
and you can see still despite how much
she kind of thrusts all this stuff off
that she does have like a taste for
this life and and not wanting to so
easily leave it behind and I felt like
her rebuke of Kristen there was more
confident than just like no no I got
duties and stuff it's like no I intend
to rule you know and then you watch that
contrast in viserys who seems like he
truly would have been better off not
being in this position just living life
and giving of you know the natural gifts
that are so apparent in him as a
character and yet don't really serve his
role as king very well and Lead his
counsel to constantly be trying to
manipulate him and stuff
and uh and two just poor poor old Auto
Hightower you got him for a half a
second here
I mean it's saying goodbye I wonder if
it was interesting I kind of like flips
the perspective in a moment yeah when
you're like man you were pretty
manipulative you definitely wanted your
own personal power gain I mean and you
did use your daughter but you're also
making some really solid points right
now back and forth and it's like yeah I
mean a fair point I'm so caught up with
all the messed up things you were doing
I wasn't really thinking about like oh
yeah you know it probably would be my my
might proceed much more smoothly yeah
I mean they both have points there
although I did have to be like as much
as it's like well you know if you hadn't
given renira that shadow of a doubt
Queen but I'm at the same time I'm like
you put her in this position and you
gave her this thankless job yeah of
having to be a baby machine you know to
push your ultimate agenda get aegon on
the throne
but it's harsh stuff but now we've got a
lot of different characters
um coming up here and there's a it's a
hell of a world uh yeah
it's it's so engrossing
it's you're just funny that opening shot
was like this is the
I like the last episode Lord of the
Rings quite a bit
um the rings of Power episode four I
liked it quite a bit but the opening
shot just made me just go
I didn't I was waiting I was reserving
it was that this is like the definition
of anti-lord of the Rings it is because
that opening shot is the most like Peter
opening sequence of her writing yeah the
amount of different like sweeping shots
they kept using is the most like Lord of
the Rings
but importance but it doesn't feel like
Sweeping in wondrous and glorious it
feels like cold and tension and oh my
God something terrible is about to
happen and it's quiet yeah and then
instead of something particularly
dramatic to punctuate it it's just a
really Stark unpleasant death for that
character who just got that cinematic
treatment yeah yeah so it's it's it did
feel like I don't think this show in any
way is trying to like make that
statement at all
um it's just something that went off in
my own subconscious no there's a there's
a lot of interesting contrast I think to
to make between these shows honestly
because there are so many similarities
in terms of how they're produced and in
terms of what the material
is to some extent but yeah one is is
very much more sort of characters where
they're intense on the surface and are
very focused on those whereas the other
one is like
people have their surface intense but
it's all about what's underneath all
that and what is unsaid or said in
Whispers And it's all a mess it's all
kind of hard to understand and hard to
pinpoint who is really is there a moral
good well I mean you watch as their
souls become corrupted because they keep
sacrificing things because of we gotta
keep things in order because of monarchy
peace we're going to keep the peace but
also have wars in the right places yeah
you just watch as these as everyone's
Souls like deteriorate as a harsh World
it really
because like everybody now like and
that's the thing that this season I
think has been a special like Game of
Thrones across the board but this season
has taken more I think this
so far has had more characters that you
could just outwardly directly sympathize
with from the get-go and I feel like
part of Game of Thrones was telling you
like those people will not make it very
far in this world and this one is
showing you those people but then
subject to the transformations to those
like sir Kristen is such a good guy
after today I wonder what that character
will be yeah I mean I I think this show
really does I see a lot of people who
are already like quick to say like to
show so much better thinking like I see
a lot of people who say that like it's
better than Game of Thrones
and of course there's there's
undoubtedly like so many similarities
undoubtedly but at the same time it's
such a different show it's it's very
very different like you kind of check in
with just the same few people every
episode in this show and it's and the
way they handle time and the way they're
handling this buildup and what the main
objective is because it's like it gets
you focused on yeah it's all about uh
ultimately ending on the consequences of
who's gonna be you know sitting on the
Iron Throne sure that's but
it it's not as big of a chessboard
ignores it and Game of Thrones kind of
kicks off a little faster into
a little bit more of that exciting I
think I think they're just very
different I think I think the way they
they make you feel is very different
yeah and um
and so I I think these are I don't know
there's a lot about what I've
experienced with these five episodes so
far that I I do find a little bit I do
prefer but I generally don't sit here
and come I don't ever really take the
time to compare and go
which one do I like more hey there just
hasn't been enough time and and B
they're they're very different yeah and
like I could just enjoy both you know
same I've done that with like better of
a call so I'm breaking bad like I
haven't
I haven't bothered to ask myself like
which one and let me just try to really
figure this out because I'm like no yeah
they're similarities but they're
different and and I think they just kind
of work together you know so that's I
think to me that's ideal that's how it
should but the production on this sounds
like chaos for like the showrunner like
I'm no I'm not coming back or one of
them leaving early
I wonder if they knew that I I guess
I've fallen I'm curious because yeah
like you don't want to hear three or
four episodes in like you're losing one
of your show Runners but part of me
wonders if knowing the response to you
know they know the response to the end
of Game of Thrones and so I bet they
were like we need as many of those hands
on deck to get this ship sailing and
then after a first season we could we
could mix it up a little bit because I
think they have Alan Taylor coming in
instead who's also done a ton of Game of
Thrones and has done good work on Game
of Thrones and so in that way I it
almost seemed like that could be just
the plan all along he's like I'll come
back for a season but it could be chaos
I'm not sure honestly it seemed like a
lot of people were surprised on the cast
so maybe not
but I don't know here's hoping it
doesn't dip it I mean it looks like this
would be let's look at this looks like
it could be a toll to put together even
if it's not chaos I could imagine that
if you're trying to put one of these
things together
that was the thing about Benny often why
is as much as I'm like you guys did not
handle this the right way I was also
like but spending like 10 plus years
doing this seems like it would take a
lot it would Age you way more than that
yeah it does seem like an incredible
undertaking to to you know guide a ship
like this I mean I wasn't even that I
wasn't even interested in the show
I wasn't either when I was announced you
know I was like who's who cares when it
was announced and then there were a
couple trailers came out I'm like I'm
not I don't even want to react to it
like now that one seems excited yeah I
saw that people were getting excited
they were they were loving the trailers
and and I did I wasn't I just wasn't
interested
um and then I'm like wow this is the
best thing on TV right now I feel like
it was the last thing on anybody's Minds
that it could be such that they would
just return us to what feels kind of
like the Heyday of Good Game of Thrones
yeah it was so much more than that yeah
but but yeah that's what's been so
rewarding is it's like oh dang already
the storytelling is the richness I
remember it and it has the sort of core
sensibilities that made those you know
particularly beloved Seasons so good but
yeah it is doing
a thing of its own that matches this
world but feels unique and distinct and
yeah I feel like you could come out of
this preferring one to the other but
also you know I feel like I I'm kind of
in a similar Camp as you I'm like I
don't really feel the need because yeah
I would put them on for slightly
different reasons you know if I'm in the
mood for this world well I think also
even though there's dragons in here
that's such kind of an accepted part of
typical fantasy that you're they just
kind of feel like an animal it's another
animal
and the way they fuse them in here too
whereas I remember Game of Thrones
opening scene dealt with the white
walkers right away yeah and it was such
a like horror Fantastical element that
sets the stage for something that will
lean more into fantasy you know yeah and
this this seems more and granted like
they did that in the opening and it was
like pretty much just very real for a
while yeah yeah and but this this seems
to just be really focused it's it's more
um what's the word more contained
and and uh it feels more real like
if there weren't dragons people might
question like this is a real historical
is it based on actual writing it's
actually half actual Mysteries of the
time yeah well and two I like that they
you have we've had a couple of dragon
set pieces that are you know big CG set
pieces but like in this episode even
like the dragons show up in like one
transitional moment and you see that
they're around and I think that
contributes to that it's like they don't
have to be the focus half the time and
you don't need every episode to have
some kind of crazy Dragon sequence they
just remind you that they're there
sometimes and I feel like that often
lends more Credence than a big dragon
that you've seen uh because yeah they're
good at selling this fantasy as not too
distant fantasy and without the white
walkers it feels that much more grounded
I think that's the thing with the with
Game of Thrones that really
distinguishes it for me is this feels
like a historical political show yeah
whereas Game of Thrones I felt was was
that but also I I would throw in the
word fantasy all the time because you
had soothsayers and you had people like
resurrecting the dead and you had the
White Walkers and there was there was a
bigger sense of like there's magic in
this realm yeah and I don't really ever
say the word fantasy with the house of
the Dragon yeah no I mean they haven't
I'm trying to think like they have their
elixirs and things like that but so far
we haven't really met any characters who
are mystical so to speak yeah it's the
only really mystical element thus far is
the dragon and even Eve dragons and even
things like the Gods like I remember
Game of Thrones having more of a sense
of like
like God's really out there whereas this
more feels like religion feels you know
in real life where it's just like yeah
it's what we believe in and sure you
know you think they're out there but I
don't get the sense that they might
actually intervene at any point in time
right right yeah well guys
Ah that's a great episode it's a good
ass show Let's uh catch up soon can't
wait for next week let's see what's
going on subscribe click that Bell leave
a like thanks to all support us on
patreon and some sort of
Mikhail Lyndon McHale we have looked up
your name on Urban Dictionary you're
gonna like it and here's what we found
the sexiest man alive
that is how we have always described
Mikhail always he is the perfect
exciting handsome and is known to have a
huge you know what oh man put it away it
is so big it gets in the way it gets
trapped bigger doors when you try to
close it down on your way to driving he
is dominant over his brothers
he with with that huge thing of his just
uses it to show I'm the only one gifted
with this and will [ __ ] on anyone who
opposes him you don't want to mess with
this guy learn that the hard way he's
got a third wheel on himself weapon
kickstand bruh he will [ __ ] on them
overall the most amazing guy yeah man
not afraid to lay down the law and if
anybody questions all you got to do is
whip it out
Chase I mean Michael McHale who you have
we're so big D energy by your bde big D
energy and uh you are ultimate Alpha you
are in our lives Mikhail thank you for
being you this is for you no wonder you
love James Bond because you got so much
in common with that hey dude you're the
next one
[Music]